hey what the hell is going on here in a
movie musical how do we get out of here
just know the script follow the script
rather the boys were gonna war reached
the end of the plot get to go home the
script although I should mention you
dying here you can die out there I miss
being bulletproof it's a special musical
episode of the flash all new Tuesday 8/7
central
hey youtubers is Charlie so we got to
talk about that crazy flash trailer but
there was also a big reverse flash
mistake on legends of tomorrow so I'm
gonna explain what that was there's a
new brand of the blasts ring giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so it's gonna be a little crazy
next week a lot of you have asked is
this going to be in the continuity of
the show like is it a one-off episode so
you kind of see what they're doing here
how they place this because it was such
a bummer at the end of the last episode
with Jay Garrick getting stuck in the
Speed Force for the rest of the season
Barry and iris breaking up whether or
not you care about that or not it's just
basically a really down moment so this
is meant to break that tension saying
here's like a fun adventure but it's
still in the continuity of the show like
they still explain how the crossover
works and how it fits in with the other
characters so Barry will come out of
this into the next like straight-up
episode of the flash and that'll be an
abra cadabra episode from the comics so
if you don't know who abracadabra is
that's actually going to be really
exciting he's a magician from the future
who basically pretends to be a magician
he just has really cool technology but
he's going to tease the identity of
Savitt are so in this 1940s episode you
have a whole bunch of people from all
the other shows crossing over
you have Malcolm Merlyn Joe in Martin
Stein playing gangsters who sort of rule
the town and go to war with each other
cisco plays a bartender win from
Supergirl plays the piano player so it
all sort of like fits into this really
silly story that's just gonna be super
nuts but remember it's part of the
future newspaper like they say music
Meister gets six-figure deal from the
Hollywood studios or I think it's a book
deal he comes out of this trying to rob
a bunch of money and then makes a bunch
of money from the Hollywood studios
writing a story about what he did flash
of a different color though moving to
legends of tomorrow reverse flash it was
a great episode for him but I think they
made a couple big mistakes with the way
his character worked so I'm gonna play
this clip and let me know if you spot
the mistakes
I don't need SuperSpeed to kick your ass
menial labor without SuperSpeed is
really quite tedious
then again I've missed working with a
fellow scientist Cisco and Caitlin and I
as you know and work together for some
time and I missed the camaraderie Legion
of Doom doesn't have karaoke Fridays I
know it's easier for you to think of me
as a monster but I've met some of
history's monsters Raymond and believe
me I'm not one of them you killed
Barry's mother twice Rex Tyler brainwash
shrimp into killing dr. myth time travel
has a way of revealing the truth to you
I'm after something much more elemental
I want to live the first smaller thing
is that they say his SuperSpeed does not
work in zero-g well that's technically
true that would only really be true if
he were floating in the vacuum of space
with nothing to push off of and he's
inside this capsule here so he could
actually run around this capsule at
SuperSpeed he might destroy it so that
might be why he's not using his speed
but like he could anchor himself and
still vibrate his hand so he'd actually
still be very deadly but the other
bigger mistake I think is that because
he's a pre flashpoint reverse flash from
before he came back and became Harrison
wells he implied that he had all the
memories of that season one reverse
flash who was secretly Harrison wells in
disguise so that should not be true what
happened is as that version of the
character was vaporized when Eddie
killed himself you saw him get kind of
sucked up into pure energy like time
basically erased him the next time we
saw you Bart Thawne during season two
was from earlier in his timeline when he
was first coming back to find out where
Barry was in the timeline oh this is the
time period the E's from now I'm gonna
try and kill him so that version of the
character had not gone back in time to
kill Barry's mother and then secretly
become Harrison wells and wait for Barry
to grow up and become the flash so when
he says he misses working with Caitlin
and Cisco it's a really great moment for
the character and I love the scene but
it shouldn't be true so that's why
I think they included it like I feel
like this is something they would argue
a lot about especially the SuperSpeed
like would he be able to run in zero-g
that's just like the type of argument
that you could see them having in the
writers room just vehemently screaming
at each other no he could run no he
couldn't run no he wouldn't remember
those people that's not the right
version of the character but whatever
their reason for including it sometimes
they just do that because it's a great
character moment and they tend to value
character work over any other concerns
religions is one of those shows that
just meant to be a little bit more fun
so it's okay for them to mess with the
timeline in a way that benefits the
story but doesn't necessarily make sense
based on the normal rules of time travel
time aberrations is the way they explain
that that's sort of the doctor who
explained her how is it that these
characters are alive if their previous
selves were killed time aberration
that's how they're still alive so that's
where you get into the spirit of Destiny
plot there's only a couple more episodes
in that moment at the end that he had
where he says I just want to live I
think is a big hat tip for season three
I think he'll be successful because the
reverse-flash is too big of a character
for you to kill off so let me know in
the comments do you actually think that
they would be bold enough to permanently
kill off the reverse-flash from the DC
TV universe there there's no way that
they would try to do something that
crazy they'll find a way to give them
their doom world so the Legion of Doom
will be successful the legends will find
a way to unright it but in all the
craziness reverse-flash will find a way
to escape
save himself so he'll come back and be
just as crazy next season but if you
were confused this is still the season 2
version of the reverse-flash so next
week what's gonna happen is as I know
it's gonna be weird there'll be like a
flash musical that you never thought
that you would watch
I'd recommend even if you're not a fan
of the idea of musicals just watch for
Easter eggs usually if there's a
character I really like that's in
something that I don't really like
usually that's my default go-to I'm like
okay well let's see if we can spot the
comic-book stuff in this but what's
coming next is I had a big conversation
with my friends Rob at comics explained
in Benny from comics story about
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet in
infinity war so I'm gonna do a theory
video about that tonight there's new
Legion that I'm gonna post tomorrow and
if you have any requests for bonus
videos this week just leave them in the
comments
below but I'll update the schedule as I
post new videos and congratulations to
the new flash ring giveaway winner plays
respect please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for that
click here for the flash episode and
click here for my non-spoiler II Iron
Fist review for the first half of the
season thank you so much for watching
will type out I'll see you guys in
tonight's video